the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire Theory video today
I want to do something a little bit
different in today's video I want to
read a theory that I have never made a
video about before and that is mostly
because this is not my actual theory I
often get emails from different people
asking me to take a look at a number of
different things in this one particular
email had a link provided along with a
message that just said hey check this
out whenever you have time so I clicked
on the link read the theory and here we
are today unfortunately I'm not quite
sure who created the theory because the
person's name is no longer visible it
actually looks like they might have even
deleted their account but I will provide
the link down below just in case any of
you want to go and read this on your own
what's interesting is this has been a
very popular theory on reddit for a
number of years the post I wanna read
has actually been given two golden
badges so obviously a lot of people
thought this was very well put together
now keep in mind this was uploaded over
four years ago and it was intended to be
a theory for the asan of Ice and Fire
books now I know some of you haven't
been able to read them yet but that's
okay because there is always that chance
that the show in the books end in a very
similar fashion since so many people did
like this theory at the time of it
getting released I want to know what
some people think about it now that we
are getting very close to the end of the
television show let's take a look at
this together than at the end of the
video let me know how much you think
they got correct if any at all the first
question says what is known of the
others the creatures themselves are
encountered in the prologue the battle
at the fist of the first men
and when Samwell Tarly kills one with a
piece of obsidian what else do we know
about them
precious little they have a language
they make some things out of ice with
the magical properties and they raise
the dead to fight for them we can infer
a few other things from conversations
about them
tormund Giantsbane has quite a bit to
say they're never far you know they
won't come out by the day not one that
old sun shining but don't think that me
they went away shadows never go away
might be you don't see them but they're
always clinging to your heels when the
snows came though snow and sleet and
freezing rain it's bloody hard to try to
find dry wood or get your kindling lit
and the cold some nights our fires just
seem to shrivel up and die nights like
that you always find some dead come the
morning lest they find you first
a man can fight the dead but when their
masters come when the white mist rises
up how do you fight a mist crow shadows
with teeth air so cold it hurts to
breathe like a knife inside of your
chest you do not know you cannot know
can your sword cut cold the interesting
thing here is that torment describes the
others as mist and shadows he never
mentions ice swords that shatter steel
or camouflage armor or anything specific
about their appearance this suggests
that he at least hasn't had direct
contact with them unless they can take
the form of a mist old man stories are
the other frequently cited sources on
the others the story were presented in
the book through old names stories and
various others is that several thousand
years ago following a mythological Age
of Heroes the others came from the far
north prior to that point they were
unknown according to the tales the
others brought with them a night that
lasted a generation or the night brought
them and essentially wiped out
civilization except for a small number
of humans that somehow were able to
drive them back all we know about this
retaliation and eventual victory is that
it resulted in the construction of the
enormous magical wall of ice that
apparently holds the others at bay
Westerosi attribute this to a figure
called the lassie ro who may or may not
be the same figure as a Zora high in
eastern figure associated with the role
or faith azure highs magic weapon may be
an allegory for the process of taming
dragons or creating Valyrian steel
either of which may involve human
sacrifice as in the story however there
is another point to consider
Melisandre the only source we have on
the others outside the tails and garbled
legends passed down orally from a time
so long ago there are no accurate
histories of it says the others are
demons of snow ice and cold and
essentially paints them as mindless
servants of a
single intelligence that opposes her
fire gone but what if she's wrong in
alternate theory
ever since the tale of the Knights King
appeared in the books people have been
speculating that it foreshadows someone
turning to the side of the others
candidates for this include Roose Bolton
and Stannis the former for an apparent
connection to magic agelessness
and a general inhuman eeriness the
latter for his hunger for power ruthless
pragmatism and possibility of snapping
and going dark when it becomes clear he
will never sit the Iron Throne the
night's king story is not a random tale
of horror it's an explanation of how the
war against the others was won the story
of the last hero is related by old man
ends what the other is closing in on the
last hero who is defenseless it has
never said that he fought or defeated or
conquered them we know that there has
already been a peace between human and
inhuman or supernatural beings and
Westeros the first men and the children
came to terms and agreed to a peace
treaty which was later broken by the
Andal invaders I propose that the last
hero was not a conqueror
but a diplomat an agreement was reached
between the men and the others it was
the others themselves that raised the
magical wall of ice not to seal
themselves off but to mark their
territory and protect themselves from a
dangerous source of fire magic to the
south of their domain this pact was
sealed as many agreements in the series
are with the marriage a stark or one of
the ancestors are the Starks married the
queen of the others and reigned at the
wall presiding jointly with a strange
bride over a sort of demilitarized zone
between the men and the others the
others then fulfilled their side of the
agreement they went away and left a man
alone men unfortunately did not keep up
their end of the bargain a large
population of them has taken up
residence on the wrong side of the wall
they may be violating some unknown and
unremembered term of the agreement could
this be why Crestor sacrifices his sons
to the others and is left alone perhaps
he simply rediscovered by accident part
of this treaty or pact we assume that
the others are doing something evil with
the babies because they look and
apparently act evil but are they
the others attacked the Nights Watch in
force but never the wildlings why simply
put the Charter of the watch goes both
ways they're not supposed to intervene
in southern affairs nor are they to
intervene in northern affairs this
brings me back to the night's king at
some point the watch had a change in
leadership and the hereditary house of
the proto stark and his other bride were
deposed and replaced by the system of
choosing this is all remembered in the
tale of the night's Kings downfall the
Nights Watch
in view of the others has broken the
treaty and the others are working to
destroy them most actively when they
invade the north in the form of the
great ranging the wildlings are simply
hearted South the others pick at their
fringes and push them towards the wall
the goal is not to exterminate them but
to get them out men are no longer
keeping their side of the agreement so
the others are no longer obligated to
keep theirs the kings of winter and the
Dragonlords if this theory is true in
ancient times the Starks and the others
were intermarried and allied they were
the kings of winter winter is coming
when Catelyn reflects on Ned's house
words she's wrong
winter is coming is not a warning of
hardship to come it is a threat the
Starks have an innate connection to
magic in the earth and the story
suggests links to the far north and the
others hinting that the Starks have
blood from beyond the wall running
through their veins this places them in
direct opposition to the Dragonlords the
Valerians are not normal human beings
either humans generally don't have
purple eyes and silver hair they are not
immune to fire but they do possess an
affinity for the heat just like a stark
and freeze to death but Ned Stark is
comfortable when sleeping in the nude in
Winterfell they also have some magical
connection to the Dragons this is a
separate topic but I propose that the
whips and sorcerers horns like dragon
binder that Danny thinks about in her a
dance with dragons chapter came about
after the magical blood of the Valerians
begin to fade and they gradually lost
control over their dragons something big
is happening with magic typically
theorists try to trace the return of
magic to either the others returning or
the Dragons being reborn but both of
these are effects pre
seated by a cause we have some clues to
what that cause might be Daenerys John
and Rob all magical children with the
traits of their ancestors were born
roughly at the same time Daenerys was
the first successful Targaryen to hatch
dragons
since they died out in John and Rob are
the first dark Ward since whenever they
stop being wargs it all comes back to
Rhaegar the return of the others isn't
in Apocalypse that must be prevented by
harnessing the power of fire to drive
them back Rhaegar knew this and he
understood that the only way to preserve
the human race is balanced between ice
and fire the others will not be so
forgiving this time humans have shown
that they can't be trusted not to
encroach on the other's territory and
play with fire magic so the others have
come to wipe them out but not out of
pure senseless malice but out of a drive
to survive the others believe that
they're saving the world from men who
will unchecked destroy it that's where
Jon Snow comes in
John is Rhaegar Targaryen Song of Ice
and Fire
that's why Jon dreams of himself wearing
armor made out of black ice with a
flaming sword in his hand John has the
blood of the Dragon Riders in the wargs
and the blood of the others through the
Starks and the blood of the dragon or
something else through the Targaryen
John's purpose and power isn't to defeat
either side the idea of one person
flaming sword and dragon or not winning
a war single-handedly in this universe
is laughably absurd instead this is to
restore the peace between them the
prince who has promised is not a Zora hi
Zora hi is the villain in the Princess
story in a Zora hi is Daenerys Targaryen
the purpose of regards prophecy and
abduction of Leona was in part to
prevent his own sister from destroying
the world by passing kingship to his
child of Ice and Fire
instead of to her all of this was
foretold in prophecy who says that the
others don't have a prophecy to what
woke up the others assuming that they
aren't mindless destroyers but an actual
culture what would bring the other self
the decline of the Nights Watch the
murder of the stark in Winterfell
and his heir by the Targaryen King or
their own prophecy of dragons returning
to destroy them
we don't know how long the others were
active or how quickly they move or
organize themselves immortal beings if
they are immortal or very long-lived
probably work on a very different time
scale way more Royce and his party were
probably not the first to encounter them
just the first time a survivor carried
the word south in fact the others may
have let Garrett live as a final warning
to the Nights Watch in the realms of men
stay out or were coming we do know that
Mance Rayder started gathering the
wildlings together they get the hell out
of Dodge well before they encounter in
the prologue suggesting that the others
were active well before that how will it
end an epic battle between the forces of
men and the others that ends in their
total defeat in banishment from the
world and a new era of peace and balance
seasons just doesn't fit with the story
as told if I'm right
the others are not so different from men
in the greater conflict not so different
from the smaller one pacts were made
backstabbing occurred and now there's
war it will end the way it did the first
time in an uneasy truce brokered by John
rather than a smashing victory of her
cold and evil by Daenerys the others may
even ally with men to destroy the threat
of the Targaryens and their dragons
before retreating north again satisfied
that men will honor their agreement for
now in the house of the undying Daenerys
has a vision of a blue rose growing from
the wall while obviously foreshadowing
that Lyanna son John is present at the
wall there is a second layer to this
that suggests a rebirth of the stark
line on the wall the same imagery is
used in the story of bale the bard Jon
Snow will become the new King at the
wall and to seal the peace take another
to bride as did the Knights king of old
not an easy or perfect or permanent
peace just a piece so basically to sum
everything up this person is saying that
the others are moving south because men
violated an ancient pact
the Knights Kings story is an account of
how the war for the dawn ended in a
piece sealed by marriage Daenerys
Targaryen in her dragons are a dangerous
force of chaos that threatens to
destabilize the world in the others are
hostile towards men because of their
betrayal of the night's king and the
overthrow of his line
their incursion into the others agreed
on territory and the danger the
Targaryen x' and their fire magic posed
to the others in the world at large
Rhaegar Targaryen fathered a son by
Layana to unite the blood of the Dragon
Riders and the other kin whether he knew
it or not John snow is that son and he
will bring the peace between the others
and the realms of men so what do you
think about this person's ideas like I
said that theory was most likely meant
for the books which in that case I
suppose there is still a good chance
that most of it could potentially happen
but I'm not so sure when it comes to the
TV show we haven't seen any signs of
there being a female white Walker
however many people do believe that Jon
Snow could become the next knight King I
know because I have made a video about
that possibility and there were people
in the comments section saying that they
think it will happen so I imagine if you
are one of those people then you would
tend to agree with at least some of what
I read here today this theory was
popular for quite some time and it did
win two golden stars or whatever but how
do you feel about it today
this goes for book readers and show
watchers let me know what you think down
below also I don't think I ever
mentioned this in a video before or not
but I have started to make some custom
t-shirts and hoodies which you can find
down below all of the different designs
do come in men's and women's sizes along
with many different colors as well I did
try to keep the prices very low to
teespring did suggest that I charge a
lot more but I wasn't trying to bust
anyone's head or wallet over a damn
shirt or hoodie so hopefully the pricing
is reasonable enough the tricky thing is
trying to stay creative when making Game
of Thrones related merchandise because
HBO has already trademarked all the best
quotes and phrases from the show so I
had to try to think of some other
directions to go in when I was trying to
create some shirts of my own now I know
most people just throw their channel
name or logo on there but I didn't want
to do something just as basic as that
but if you are interested then let me
know or just click on the link down
below anyways I want to thank all of you
for watching the video and I also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
supporting the channel already Happy
Holidays everyone I will see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you